all right happy sunday guys so excited
to be at area
51 and it's going to be 15. it's the
confusing part i always think it's 512
but it's 15. yeah it's 15. there's even
a 1-5 over there
uh we're gonna enter this exhibit so
we're at meow wolf we're gonna go inside
it's gonna be meow wolf but we're gonna
do omega mart
and i don't even know how to explain it
to you
so i'm just excited to go
what do you know about it
i don't even know i just know it's crazy
it's like i don't know maybe like an
acid trip but in real life without doing
the drugs
is what it looks like so i don't even
know let's go
ready let's go
[Music]
this is crazy
[Music]
[Music]
this is so cool
[Music]
okay so what do you want to do so we
have
babe
so we have omega heart over there
okay
or
we can just walk around for now let's
walk around first because this place
looks huge so i want to get a good gist
of what's going on before we go off into
the separate ones let's do it
[Music]
like unique different things so here is
the outside of omegamar which we will do
and say for the very end
oh my god i want this tree in my life
look at this
[Music]
do oh yeah we need to do that yeah
this place
[Music]
this place reminds me of like a sober
race
like
it feels like you're at a giant massive
like edc
but you're sober and it's a family
they just have the kids over there too
it's cool so cool
look at her jacket
[Music]
i want your jacket lady
i want that vest
[Applause]
so i hear that meow wolf was created by
a bunch of artists who were just so
tired of the art scene so they all got
together
oh my god look at that you know
and decided to do their own thing no
rules
no regulations nothing
just pure art however they wanted to do
it and i'm so happy that they did that
look at how beautiful this place is
[Music]
what is that over there
what look at how cool this place looks
oh my gosh
rocket fizz
let's go inside who is it look at this
wall
[Music]
what i'm cool
[Applause]
baking soda with chocolate i feel like
we've done this for jk party this place
is crazy i wish this was around when we
were doing jk party all of oh my god
black olive soda mustard soda look at
that one
gross buffalo wings sweet corn
maple syrup
martian soda
what do you see dude
what is that thing
juicy drop oh some of this stuff's
normal yeah yeah
blacklist fish is never normal
i know i just offended so many countries
right now i'm sorry but it's just
it's just not good y'all stop it don't
try to sell it to me like it's good
[Music]
the decor in this place is
so [ __ ] sick
[Music]
uh
whoa
yeah we are inside
a pretend
so this is like a twilight zone type of
supermarket where everything is crazy
like this this is like fry but it's
el omega lomega and everything is
different
everything here is custom it's custom
look at those hot sauces
like power wings so we can buy these i
know look at this there's a spray bottle
on there
are we crazy you see that
yes we are all crazy
[Music]
what is it
[Music]
okay so
this unlocks all the computers and i
guess you get like a different alternate
route oh there's something there too
so it's like kind of a game you can go
through the game or we can just go
through the
different areas here yeah tiger's gonna
want to go to the tent
taika let's go to the tent let's go go
go
go sorry
[Music]
oh no
it turns into it turns into a tunnel
it turns into a tunnel oh my god oh my
god your shoes
holy crap
i'm on all fours right easy or worse
[Music]
where did you start up there
i know we started just from the omega
mark
and look what this is what in the world
we are
no longer
where we started from
this is so sick
so
what the hell is
[Music]
okay so
there's a lot of stuff going on here
that i do not know how to explain
so you're gonna be hearing a lot of wows
and oh my god
because i've never seen anything like
this in my life and i cannot tell you
how [ __ ] excited i am to be here
right now because
[Music]
what is this okay want to keep going
yeah let's go okay
i don't know how to explain
[Applause]
[Music]
this is so
there's another tunnel okay let's go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
there's something special about this
painting
whoa look if you look at the uh
depending on the lights yeah i'm going
to change it to other art
you see different parts i do i do
[Music]
whoa what is this
[Music]
super cool
[Music]
what is it dude i don't know but look
there's all these little ferns and stuff
[Music]
a ton of artists
had to put this on and install it like
the amount of work that went into this
place is insane and there's goo i don't
know if you can see it this is new but
they put jewels on the glue
oh
we're definitely in another dimension
here
and i think that's what they're trying
to portray and i think they did an
outstanding job
let's keep moving so now we're going to
level two
i think
and there's i think one more level above
us no no whoa what is in there
[Music]
[Music]
what's in there
[Music]
it's just us
maybe someone's looking at us there's a
big bug
[Music]
these big bugs
so we're going to level three of
whatever the spaceship thingy is
i am really tall
it's like an electric drum machine
[Music]
[Music]
okay go
wait
oh my god
[Music]
okay we were just down there okay i know
where i'm at
[Music]
wait someone just went through the wall
over there
someone coming out of the wall
[Music]
[Music]
is this place nuts or what
does this even make sense who are these
people
[Music]
i even feel that the people that work
here are part of cast
and that we should be asking them
questions honestly no you know what i
mean
i feel that the people that work here
are cast and they're like part of this
whole thing i think so i think they are
like all these people on here that was
really cool
oh
but she looks like the custodian for
this place but she's really just she's
just an actress yeah because you were
given a card to figure out some clues
yeah but we're obviously not playing
because this guy is just
well guy what is that
okay this place is crazy you see why i'm
like i don't know how to explain any of
this
other than wow and holy crap and what is
that it's like you're in the future and
on drugs at the same time i love it
crazy
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the caps
okay
okay guys i know where i'm at okay
so this is where when we crawled into
that hole from the store that's where we
came from
i got it i kind
okay let's go there's a door there
this one right here
let's hope it opens okay
oh it doesn't open it doesn't open pull
as hard as you can go
i can't i think it's locked i do have to
go from the other way okay let's go
back here
there's a hole there that people are
going in and out of oh
what does it say
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh my god i want this in my house
yes yes yes yes yes
oh my god
can we get this can we get some version
of this i don't even know what this is
but get it
okay monkey where do you want to go
i'll follow you
[Music]
[Music]
stop it oh my god
look at this butcher
[Music]
still have to mom
i think that's it we're done
so this is the lounge area look at this
i love these
[Music]
there's apps throwing if you're
interested
oh
let's go in here
[Music]
whoa
i need more black light in my life
[Music]
look at the lava lamp oh dude i had
all of these guys in my room in high
school it was i had so many on the walls
and the ceiling when i turned off the
lights
there was it was like still so bright in
there because i had somebody go in the
dark stars it was really red
[Music]
what's in your hands what's that i don't
know this one this one
purple
all the kids are going nuts over these
have you guys seen these all they
literally do is pop it
and then turn around and pop it again
how
genius is this [ __ ] toy
because all the kids like it these days
right you just press it it's like the
new fidget spinner i think it is and
then you flip it around and you do it
again and it never stops yeah
it's like i love this thing i know he
does genius damn look at that
oh damn what is that what i love it the
black light is um
making it look really cool i designed it
like that on purpose good job baby with
the black light in our house yep
dude i want this tree look at this
oh my god it looks beautiful on camera
oh my god
i love it
wow
hey little farrell
look at that
[Music]
yeah this makes me uncomfortable dude no
no
okay so now we're going to
level 2
of area 15.
whoa
see what we see
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that golf looks really fun it does
that looks funner than real though
so look at the bottom floor from the top
here second floor
oh
that was the candy store we went into
and i mean there's a ton of stuff
to do here that's also very family
friendly and
date friendly so definitely check it out
to top it all off they have an arcade
adult
arcade and bar
so if you want to get away
[Music]
all right well thank you so much um
definitely check it out area 15 las
vegas uh first date family you just want
to get away something different want to
get inspired come through
it's actually free to get in but all the
attractions it does cost some money not
very expensive so check it out we'll see
you next time bye